first before we get started thank first
of all thank you so much for coming into
the studio before we get started the
only reason Collider gets to be active
is because we partnered up with House of
Aurora which is where we're at right now
and I want to give a huge thank you to
House of Aurora Aurora for being a great
partner sponsor for letting me do stuff
like this I just want to start and give
them a huge shout out so you guys had
your party here last night at this space
were you more nervous to make the movie
or sing in front of like the VIP crowd
um I was well more nervous to make the
movie and singing was just lovely it's
like being able to celebrate sharing
this story for the first time to an
audience which is what it's all about
everyone watching this interview will
not have seen the movie yet and I hate
asking generic questions but can you
sort of talk about what the film is
about who you play etc etc the film is
about a girl from Glasgow who wants to
get the hell out there and make it to
Nashville as a country singer which
sounds like a reasonable plan because
she's got an amazing voice they by
Jessie Buckley but she's got two young
children and a mom who just wants her to
get a normal job and just to settle down
she just come out of jail her mom wants
her to have a normal life but she's got
this burning dream to sing country music
in Nashville I have to ask you where the
hell did the idea come from
you know wow did this thing germinate I
am a lifelong country music fan it's
been my obsession since I was 12 years
old and surprising enough it's sort of
in the water in Glasgow where I'm from
it's really really popular there's a
tiny wee replica Grand Ole Opry which is
in the movie and it's popular all over
the places where people are not very
good at expressing their feelings it's
it's you get two and a half minutes of a
catharsis and every country song and for
people who are not used to articulating
how they feel and it's the best so
that's why it's pretty popular I
thinking in Glasgow and also you know
cause of mass immigration to Canada and
the states from Scotland there's a sort
of longing that permeates country music
and I guess it appeals to us because
we stayed behind and we miss you you
went and we stayed so all of that was
going on but yeah it was my chance to
write about my hometown and my passion
country music how did you to connect did
you get the script through like an agent
a friend how did you hear about this
thing I got given the script by the
producer Fay ward but I'd actually known
about it for a long time and we'd known
each other for some I guess 10 years I
mean almost someone like that we'd sort
of kind of come up together and in doing
sort of emerging talent schemes and we
knew each other's work and wanted to
work together and almost work together a
few times before so so when they gave me
the script I I sort of had an inkling
that I liked it already and then just
from very calm page three I think that I
was I was hooked and from that moment
onwards I knew I had to join join the
exactly in you get the script how much
changed from when you first got the
script to what people are actually going
to see on screen I don't know I mean I
guess some but like everything it's all
that all this I mean basically the
Rosaleen is the same and the whole Orgel
kind of the whole journey is basically
saying well guess there's a whole bunch
of small things that inevitably changed
as you go through and you find locations
and you find actors and it develops and
evolves but essentially I think they're
kind of the trajectory and the main
character is all pretty much the same so
this movie as good as the idea is and
everything you want to do it's not gonna
work unless you have the the person that
the audience can root for and get behind
and who has the voice so yep talk talk a
little bit about how you guys first met
and was it quote-unquote love at first
sight
I'm a just like you just recently come
at our school right uh yeah yeah I think
I just come out maybe a year or two
years and we worked together we did warm
piece together different character yeah
quite none like sad character Rosen is
not none like no Antonin and then we
stayed in touch and stayed friends and I
have to ask at the time did you know she
could sing like and really sing well
there's some singing warm piece Ashley I
mean again is sort of very different but
I knew she could sing and I knew I knew
you'd sung and had done yeah and we're
singing in the past so yeah I did but I
it was I I loved working with Jesse in
one piece and and you know she was don't
find people that's special very often
and I wanted to try and you know find
someone to work with her again and then
I read the script and just immediately I
saw I really look at the character Jesse
was in my mind for it so I read that the
first time I read the script that I'd
read it with Jesse in mind for that
character and I knew that that was the
only person that was gonna be playing
that with and playing that role so it
happened pretty quickly and she
fortunately loved it as much as I did
and then we basically got Anna Colden
headlock and the way we went so what is
it like that first sit down or was it a
text message what was it like that first
meeting where he's telling you hey I
have a script that is a hell of a part
uh well I think we were in a pub here in
that like oh I've got this great script
I want to send it to you and you know I
mean I hadn't been actually offered to
film at that point I was just yeah yeah
and I think I was away filming then and
I read it and I just completely loved it
and then I met Nicole
which I don't know that felt like love
at first sight as well cuz we just after
I got I don't know if I had been offered
it if I don't it then anyway and I'm
actually doing and we just fell in love
but it's been such a like incredibly
collaborative and like it's been one big
family we've all from George Steele are
amazing
Nicole and Tom we've all shared and
we've all like we've all been making
this story together it's not one
person's story it's everybody's story
and everybody put a little bit of their
heart in it so we're at the Toronto Film
Festival when did you find out that
you've gotten the film in and what does
it mean for each of you to be here I've
never been to Canada by the way there
was a country bar like really close to
here oh the mechanical bull and
everything by it's like a litter I it's
literally right like five blocks down
they've thrown some parties there before
like premiere party amazing that's
tonight Jesse but you should go I don't
really have a very interesting answer to
this except for the truth which is like
I was saying rather dully about
immigration from Scotland to Canada in
America in my family of the ten siblings
of my grandmother everyone left who come
to America in Canada and I've spent the
time here in Toronto meeting all these
relatives who still have kind of strange
mixed Glaswegian Canadian accents and
which has been really nice but I think
you should just cut that someone gives a
toss about my family I well we had at
the screening in London where Kerry came
and watched the movie and I
had a film in Toronto before and I was
desperate to come for ages and just you
know we're such a massive prestigious
festival and so it seems like the
producer Fay Ward was there and she met
Carrie afterwards and so as soon as they
as I knew the screening was over I was
on the phone what did she think what'd
she say
her facial expressions could she give
anything away but you know I think as
soon as you came out for the screenings
she it was clear that she really loved
the movie and then we found out
reasonably quickly after that so if it
was if it was a real so I'm such an
amazing feeling to have your film
showing as part of a festival this
festival but but also particularly came
real last night just sitting with the
audience and showing it to 1200 people
and Ryerson and having such a great
response and just to to to to get to go
to pour like this he was saying you pull
your heart and your soul into something
and and and you know all that time and
effort and love into something and then
to be able to share that with such an
appreciative audience is an incredible
feeling yeah I mean it's I I was I love
Toronto I think it's just one of my
favorite cities and I was here last year
with a film and to get to come back
again and I mean the audience here are
just the best and they just want to be
entertained and they love it's just a
huge honor and it's like this year
there's so many incredible films and
it's such an honor
oh my god like my favorite it's like
it's an such an honor to be part of that
like it really is for you when I when I
talk to a lot of actors they always talk
about how the first thing figuring out
the character the first thing of the
character is the hardest and once they
get that that it's so much easier to
sort of figure everything out do you
find that the case and what was the
first thing that you did try to get into
this character
well this script was just so incredible
in this that you know he I always was
returning to that because that's where
Rosen's pulse was start you know
yeah I suppose with learning to love
country music because I thought it was a
bit hick before I I did it and now I'm
completely obsessed by it so I am
chewing on some hair something anyway
that's why I did I just because country
music is like where her passion what's
driving her passion sure um yeah that's
very sterile I'm the gas black sedan
dude um had you done a test screening or
like sort of friends-and-family
screening prior to showing it here and
what did you learn from that early
screening that may be impacted the
finished film huh that's a good question
it's we in edit editing process we
always knew that there was a really
strong emotional story there and there
were parts of the film that worked
really well right from the very
beginning like the ending for example as
always right from the very first
assembly who's always connected and been
strong emotionally but there were a
number of parts throughout the film
they've taken some real careful
fine-tuning to kind of to make it really
resonate you know and I kind of the key
building blocks were all there but just
kind of fine-tuning and actually I think
this film more than more than most that
I've worked on that that careful
fine-tuning has really helped to make it
sing like and and those friends and
family screens were particularly we had
like we had a particular kind of there
was a gnarly part in the middle of the
film where Rosalind goes to London that
we've been China that we couldn't get
right and just the feedback from that
just helped us think around it and to
think outside the box and wind up
picking up a little scene there and so
it's just kind of small often small and
subtle things that make a big difference
everyone has been coming through the
studio we've been playing something
called get to know your TIF attendee
these are harmless questions I promise
we're about to play for you what TV show
would you love to guest spot on
what TV show would you love to guess
direct and what TV show would you love
to guessed right I've never had such
silence I would love to have written
transparent I was gonna say transparent
reporting transparent please for me
there's this show in the UK called the
detectorists and it's which is by
Mackenzie Crook and it's the most
delightful TV series that I'd love to do
one of those but unfortunately
Mackenzie's very does it all very
selfish selfish like that um do you guys
have a favorite sci-fi or a fantasy film
I don't know I'm not into sci-fi okay
that's fine
Wheatley the first thing that comes to
mind is primer from I don't know get 15
years ago is that that's a great movie
yeah I've never seen a sci-fi or a
fantasy film and all my puffs so I've
got nothing to say to that one Wow it's
fine
what what films scared you as a kid
first film I ever saw was from cold
therapy or gills and Darby O'Gill and
the little people and was about I'm a
leprechaun never gettin this banshee
which is like a kind of grim reaper came
to take one of the old men and I
remember just watching and crying my
eyes out it was the scariest thing in
the world was for me those guys got the
toilet four years
[Laughter]
mine was Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory I couldn't handle the surreal
Ness and I was physically sick on the
carpets when Violet Beauregarde
got blown up and pushed around the
corridors but do you collect anything
a lot of debate wondering my kids
collect pokemon cards to an extreme
level I feel like everywhere I'm moving
my hands at pokemon cards ice collect
stamps I don't know where they are
actually stones when I was a kid you
know you like paint stones and sell them
I saved the road you know well I didn't
know I'd like to I'd like to collect
books I like spec first addition to
books yeah I've actually heard that from
a number of people be surprised how many
people after their directors collect
first edition books
yeah postcards
if we were a professional operation we'd
have another mic I just clicked new
country music tunes so every week I'm
just creating a new list for the week's
work of country music my wee boy Guthrie
yeah my my kids I think it's I think
we've got carve and oh boy the scene
Kerry and I think it's like this sea
near that Caravan is there a movie that
you've watched more than 10 times the
Blues Brothers Tootsie um what's your
favorite all right I mean to be honest
whatever ones added us I liked them when
I finally reached Nashville for the
first time I bought myself a pair of
cowboy boots which I wear most days I
last not today I can't walk more about
wearing like it's just no it just
transforms me in my mind into a country
singer if I'm sitting down but if I'm
walking around then I'm just an idiot
from Glasgow who's got sore feet and
can't walk in any kind of heel it's
taken me that long to write the scripts
I think no I only got the I only got the
boots about six years into tooling away
on the script did you say if you have a
pair I don't really I like these ones
West Toronto fresh you were wanted to be
but where he would kid any saw
performance did you see a movie I was in
abandoned but I wasn't very good so I
thought if I find something else my
friends were better than me I became a
lawyer and was very miserable doing that
and that was kind of useful for things
to build up and build up and build up
and all to come in writing I think
watching my mom sing is the little girl
my mom's a harpist and a singer so yeah
watching her sing I I always wonder
because sometimes it's like someone saw
like a performance in a movie and I
changed my mind
of course just made a mistake that's
because I was only here an hour ago for
the party - and growing up watching a
British comedian called Victoria Wood
and her writing and her performance
performance made me want to write before
I run out of time I do have to I am
really looking forward to the aeronauts
what can you tease people about the film
which is you know obviously the next
project for him it's a hell of a ride in
the balloon well you put together -
pretty good actors talk can you just
tease people a little bit yeah it's it's
it's it's basically those two actors
Eddie Redmayne and Felicity Jones who go
up in a balloon in 1862 and who get into
all sorts of problems along the way so
it's a sort of most sort of action movie
in the sky I guess but it's it's also
kind of a pressure cooker in which the
the to those who characters sort of go
on a journey together and discover
things about themselves and each other
along the way I really mean it sincerely
congratulations on being a part of TIFF
thank you so much for coming in the
studio I wish you nothing but success
thank you
[Music]